[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم اقتحم موشي فيجلين النائب رئيس
الكنيسه الاسرائيلي الحرم القدسي الشريف
صباح الاحد وذلك في سياق تصعيد اسرائيلي
ضد الاقصى شمل اغلاق المسجد امام المصلين
قبل ايام اضافه الى دعوه مسؤولين
اسرائيليين لتغيير الوضع القائم فيه وفتحه
بصوره دائمه امام المصلين اليهود نتوقف مع
هذا الخبر لنناقش في محورين اولا ما مغزى
ارتفاع وتيره التحركات الاسرائيليه التي
تستهدف الاقصى خلال الفتره
الماضيه وما المطلوب فلسطينيا وعربيا
لمواجهه مرامي ومخططات اسرائيل ال الخاصه
[موسيقى]
بالاقصى فيما يشبه عمليه توزيع ادوار قاد
نائب رئيس الكنيست الاسرائيلي والرجل
الثاني في حزب الليكو الحاكم موشي فيجلين
قاد مجموعه من تسعه مستوطنين يهود متطرفين
تحرسهم الشرطه واقتحم بهم المسجد الاقصى
وذلك بعد يوم واحد من دعوه لضروره التهدئه
والبعد عن الاستفزاز صدرت عن الرجل الاول
في حزب الليكود نفسه رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو بيد ان ما
فعله فيجلين على غرابته ليس تصرفا معزولا
وانما هو خطوه ضمن سلسله تحركات اسرائيليه
تستهدف المسجد الاقصى في الفتره
الاخيره لم تعد مجرد افعال منقطعه بل حمله
منسقه موشي فيجلين نائب رئيس الكنيست
يقتحم الحرم القدسي وقبله فعل رموز من
اليمين اليهودي وهذا وسط اجراءات تتصاعد
يقول الفلسطينيون انها تستهدف هويه الحرم
نفسه لا مدينه القدس وحسب فلم يعد الهدف
هو التهويد بل تفكيك الهويه الاسلاميه
والعربيه للمدينه والحرم فالاستاد في
التوحش حوله في حي سلوان لاحطت بطوق
استيطاني خالص يجري هذا بالتوازي مع حمله
يقود فلين ويهو جليك ووزير الاسكان اوري
ارييل تسعى لاستنساخ تجربه الحرم
الابراهيمي في الخليل وتكرارها في القدس
اي تقسيم الحرم القدسي مكانيا وزمان وذاك
مشروع قديم ظل طي الادراج في مكاتب الساسه
والمخيال اليهودي منذ احتلال المدينه عام
67 ويريد هؤلاء تطبيقا عمليا لنظريه قديمه
لم تختبر لديهم بعد وهي ان تكون المدينه
باسرها بما فيها الحرم تحت السياده
الاسرائيليه التامه ما يعني التجاوز على
ما يعرف بالدوري الاردني الخاص في الاقصى
الذي تعترف به اسرائيل رسميا وضرب عرض
الحائط بالاتفاق بين عباس والعاهل الاردني
على ما عرف بالوصايه الهاشميه على الحرم
من شان هذا تحويل الصراع الى ديني بامتياز
فيما يذهب البعض ومنهم الرئيس الفلسطيني
محمود عباس الى ان اغلاق الحرم قبل ايام
يرقى الى اعلان حرب يمضي اخرون ابعد قليلا
فما يحدث في الاقصى وله ما كان له ان يتم
لولا موافقه نتنياهو شخصيا على ما يحدث
وفي راي هؤلاء فان الرجل يستبق سيناريوهات
محتمله في المنطقه قد تنتهي بملف الدوله
الفلسطينيه الى الامم المتحده مجددا ويعضد
من هذه السيناريوهات اعتراف السويد
وبرلمانات اوروبيه بالدوله الفلسطينيه
والحال هذه يسعى نتنياهو لارساء حقائق
جديده على الارض تحول دون ان تكون القدس
عاصمه لهذه الدوله
وان يكون الحرم القدسي تحت سياده
الفلسطينيين كامله في المستقبل بهذا يسعى
نتنياهو لارجاع التاريخ الى عام 67 ثانيه
لاعاده الصراع الى القرون
الوسطى موضوع حلقتنا هذا نناقشه مع ضيوفنا
من القدس احمد الرويضي مستشار ديوان
الرئاسه الفلسطينيه لشؤون القدس ومن القدس
ايضا خالد زبار عضو المكتب السياسي لل
الحكه الاسلاميه داخل الخط الاخضر ومدير
مؤسسه القدس للتنميه ومن الناصره ينضم
الينا اليف صباغ الكاتب والباحث في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه نرحب بضيوفنا جميعا وابدا معك
استاذ احمد الرويضي في القدس يعني سلسله
التصعيد هذه ليست جديده بدءا من رفع سن
المسموح لهم بالصلاه الى ال عاما وانتهاء
باقتحام نائب رئيس الكنيست لباح المسجد
الاقصى ما مغزى كل هذه
الممارسات اولا مساء الخير لك ولضيوفك
الكرام ولمستم معين الحقيقه اسرائيل الان
تعمل في الربع ساعه الاخيره من اجل تنفيذ
برنامجها في المسجد الاقصى المبارك هي
تريد ان تقفز مباشره الى التقسيم المكاني
على طريق اقامه الهيكل المزعوم الذي يدعون
وبالتالي هي تع
في طريقين طريق نطلق عليه نظريه التجفيف
بمعنى ابعاد المسلمين عن المسجد الاقصى
المبارك تدريجيا بحصر الاعداد المسموح لها
بدخول المسجد وبالتالي ربط هؤلاء بهم من
اكثر من 50 عاما ومنع الشباب والمرابطين
والمرابطات من التواجد في المسجد الاقصى
المبارك من اجل تسهيل المرور بالنسبه
لتنفيذ البرنامج الذي هو في شاكلته او في
مظهره الدخول مستوطنين لكن الموضوع ابعد
من ذلك هو تقسيم مكاني واقامه الهيكل
مزعوم الموضوع الثاني ايضا او النظريه
الثانيه ان اسرائيل تريد ارتكاب حدث خطير
على غرار ما حصل بالحرم الابراهيمي الشريف
بالخليل هي ارتكبت المجزره هناك ومن ثم
على ظهر المجزره قفزت الى التقسيم المكاني
للحرم الابراهيمي بالتالي نفس السيناريو
هي ارادته في المسجد الاقصى المبارك خلال
الثلاث شهور الاخيره وبالتالي هي حاولت
اطلاق الرصاص الحي الرصاص المطاطي وقنابل
الغاز وقنابل الصوت في المسجد القبلي في
المسجد الاقصى المبارك والذي كان سيؤدي لا
سمح الله الى حرق السجاد او ارتكاب مجزره
لا سمح الله او اي حدث خطير تبني عليه
التقسيم المكاني لكن الهدف البعيد
للاحتلال الاسرائيلي هو السيطره على
المكان بالكامل محو الطابع العربي
الاسلامي لهذا المكان وبالتالي القدس
كامله محو طابعها العربي الاسلامي المسيحي
وخلق مدينه بارث يهودي مصطنع وبالتالي نحن
نقول احنا بوضع صعب جدا نعم يعني كل
الاقتحامات في السابق كان يقوم بها
مستوطنون متطرفون او مجموعات من المتطرفين
الان يقوم بها نائب رئيس الكنيست الرجل
الثاني في الليكود يعني جهه رسميه ماذا
يعني
ذلك اولا في كل المرات كان هناك
السؤال السؤال للاستاذ اليف صبا نحن لا
نفرق على الاطلاق ما بين عفوا عفوا استاذ
احمد رويضي السؤال موجه للاستاذ اليف صباخ
تفضل مساء الخير موشي فيجلين حقيقه هو
الرجل الثاني في حزب الليكود وهو المنافس
الاكبر ل من من الجهه اليمينيه لبيبي
نتنياهو وبالتالي له له وزن في داخل الكود
وله وزن في داخل الحكومه ولا يقوم باي عمل
دون موافقه رسميه او غير رسميه من حكومه
اسرائيل ولو ارادت حكومه اسرائيل وقوى
الامن الاسرائيليه ان تمنع موش فيجلين من
اقتحام الاقصى هو ومجموعه من المستوطنين
او مجموعه من مساعديه لفعل ذلك ولكن بما
ان الشرطه هي التي تغطي هذا الاقتحام هذه
المره وكل المرات السابقه الشرطه غطت هذا
الاقتحام بالتالي تصبح حكومه اسرائيل هي
المسؤوله وهي من وراء وهي التي شرعت هذا
الاقتحام للمسجد الاقصى
المبارك الهدف الاسرائيلي لا يختلف هذه
المره عن المرات السابقه كل المرات
السابقه كل السنوات السابقه هناك هدف
اسرائيلي لتقسيم الاقصى بالطابق العلوي
والطابق السفلي ضمن مخطط بعيد
المدى وبعدم اعتراف لحق المسلمين في
الاقصى المبارك الامر
الاهم هو في الظرف اسرائيل ك كدوله
ومؤسسات تتميز بان لها خطط كثيره في
الادراج وتنتهز الفرص بشكل جيد حتى تستطيع
ان تنفذ هذه الخطط قد توجد الخطه ع سنوات
و20 سنه في الدرج ولكن لم يكن هناك ظرف
مناسب اليوم الظرف العربي للاسف الشديد
تعتقد اسرائيل انه مناسب جدا لها الظرف ال
الفلسطيني هناك ارتباك فلسطيني ما زال قبل
ح الحرب على غزه وبعد الحرب على غزه ما
زال هناك ارتبا ارتباك فلسطيني وخلل في
التوازن الفلسطيني الداخلي وبالتالي تعتقد
اسرائيل انها تستطيع ان تفرض مخططها على
ال في القدس طيب استاذ خالد زبر
يتضمن رساله اسرائيليه وهو اقتراب مجلس
الامن
ا اقتراب مجلس الامن من مناقشه قضيه هامه
جدا وهو الاعتراف بالدوله الفلسطينيه
اعترافا كاملا في الايام القريبه القادمه
وفي الش في هذا الشهر وبالتالي هذا يخيف
اسرائيل وتريد ان تفرض نفسها في القدس
الشرقيه وتقول للعالم ولمجلس الامن ان اي
قرار منكم يصدر منكم ي عترف بالحق
الفلسطيني سيتسبب في عدم استقرار وسيتسبب
في توتر امني في القدس وبالتالي لن تكون
اسرائيل هي الطرف الصامت والقابل بهذا
الموضوع هناك اطراف اسرائيليه رسميه وغير
رسميه يمكن ان تتصدى لقرار مجلس الامن هذه
رساله لمجلس الامن ا السباق لقرار مجلس
الامن الدولي برايك وقبل ذلك استاذ خالد
زبرقه كان استاذ اليف الصباغ يقول ان
اسرائيل تحاول استغلال الظرف العربي
والاقليمي حولها لتمرير مخططاتها ربما
تبعت الاتهامات الموجهه من رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو بال توجيه
اللوم في التوتر الحاصل في القدس المحتله
خاصه في محيط المسجد الاقصى على ما سماها
بجهات اسلاميه متطرفه تريد اشعال الشرق
الاوسط حسب تعبيره انتم كجه اسلاميه داخل
الخط الاخضر ك كي ف تردون على مثل هذا
الكلام اولا نحن نرد ان المسجد الاقصى
المبارك هو مسجد وهو حق اسلامي خالص عربي
فلسطيني لا يملك الاحتلال فيه اي ضره حق
وجود الاحتلال في المسجد الاقصى المبارك
وفي القدس عامه هو وجود باطل وهذا الوجود
يجب ان يزول في اقرب فرصه ممكنه
اي الاحتلال الاسرائيلي غير شرعي في
المسجد الاقصى المبارك لا يملك اي شرعيه
لا في المسجد الاقصى المبارك ولا في القدس
هذا على على مستوى القانون الدولي هو قوه
تقوم قوه احتلال
ولذلك نحن نقول للاحتلال الاسرائيلي ان من
يقوم بالاعتداء على الشباب الفلسطينيين
المقدسيين ليل نهار من يقوم بقتل الشباب
الفلسطينيين بدم بارد من يقوم بهدم البيوت
من يقوم بمنع المسلمين من الصلاه والتواصل
مع المسجد الاقصى المبار
من يقوم بمحاوله فرض واقع جديد داخل مسجد
الاقصى المبارك من من يقوم
باغلاق مداخل المسجد الاقصى المبارك
الخارجيه من يقوم بمحاوله سحب السياده
الاردنيه عن المسجد الاقصى المبارك هو هو
وفقط هو الذي يسبب التوتر والتوترات في
المسجد الاقصى المبارك وفي وفي محيط
المسجد الاقصى المبارك ما يقوم به
الفلسطينيون داخل الخط الاخضر وداخل داخل
مدينه القدس هو الحفاظ على وجودهم الحفاظ
على واقعهم الحفاظ على حقهم الذي يريد
الاحتلال ان يسلبه منهم الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ان وقف يعني موقف ال ال يعني
ال البعيد عن المسجد الاقصى المبارك ان لم
يعتدي على المسجد الاقصى المبارك ان اوقف
مستوطنيه وموظفيه من اقتحام المسجد الاقصى
المبارك ليل نهار وهذه التصريحات التي ان
دلت على شيء فانما تدل على انه يوجد هناك
مخطط احتلالي لفرض على المسجد الاقصى
المبارك انا باعتقادي انه هو الذي يتسبب
بكل هذه التوترات داخل القدس و وفي محيط
المجد طيب استاذ احمد الرويضي يعني
بنيامين نتنياهو اكد ان الوضع في الاقصى
سيظل كما هو على ما هو عليه لكن هناك
مطالبات
من
مسؤولين سياسي وسياسيين بتقسيم الاقصى
زمانيا ومكانيا اوقات وامكن لليهود وايضا
اوقات للمسلمين كيف يعني يمكن قراءه هذه
الرسائل اولا دعيني اتفق مع الاستاذ اميل
قطار الفلسطيني الى الامم المتحده انطلق
منذ عامين بالاعتراف الاممي بالجمعيه
العموميه والان توجهنا الى مجلس الامن
لتحديد فتره زمنيه وسقف زمني لانهاء هذا
الاحتلال لانه الاداره الامريكيه تتحدث عن
حل الدولتين العالم يتحدث عن حل للدولتين
بالتالي يجب ان تقام الدوله الفلسطينيه
على حدود الرابع من حزيران عام
1967 وهذا لا يمكن ان يستمر الى الابد
وانما لابد من تحديد فتره زمنيه انتهي
فيها هذا الاحتلال اسرائيل تريد ان تعرقل
هذا القطار او ان تزيع عن اتجاهه الصحيح
وبالتالي نلاحظ اما اعلان عن مشاريع
استيطان اما الاعتداء على المسجد الاقصى
المبارك قتل الناس كما تم في مدينه القدس
ايه هدم منازل اغلاق مؤسسات وغيرها من
الاجراءات الاسرائيليه ال
المعروفه ثانيا نتنياهو الان في خانه صعبه
وبالتالي هو يريد ان يتهرب من الاستحقاقات
القادمه بفرض الامر الواقع في القدس لانه
يدرك بانه لا لا دوله فلسطينيه بدون القدس
ولن يكون هناك اي مسؤول فلسطيني يقبل باي
دوله فلسطينيه بدون القدس وبالتالي كل
اجراءاته الان تتركز في مدينه القدس
ومحيطها ويركز بشكل خاص على المسجد الاقصى
المبارك هو لا يدرك انه لا يستطيع خدام
خداع العالم الى الابد بالتالي اليوم حاول
ان يخرج على صباحا بتصريح بانه يطلب من
وزرائه بعدم اثاره الفلسطينيين في القدس
انا اقول ان هذا مجرد تصريح للراي العام
الدولي اكثر منه للمجتمع الاسرائيلي لانه
هو في النهايه في الوقت الذي يصدر فيه هذا
التصريح واعطى الضوء الاخضر لفلين
وللشرطة الجمله على المواطنين اعتقالات
لاطفال وشباب صغار لاسباب مختلفه بالتالي
انا لا استطيع ان احدد الى اين الامور الى
اين يمكن ان تتجه اذا ما استمر الاعتداء
الاسرائيلي على المقدسيين بهذا الشكل ولا
احد يستطيع ان يتوقع وهذا ما ابلغنا به
الاطراف الدوليه اسرائيل تلعب بالنار
عندما تعتدي على المسجد الاقصى المبارك هي
تريد ان تحول هذا الصراع من صراع سياسي
الى صراع ديني ستحرق ايادي الجميع بالصراع
الديني في عبر العالم هناك مليار نصف مسلم
صحيح موقفهم الان ضعيف لا نراه بصوت عالن
لكن لا سمح الله لو حدث امر خطير في
المسجد الاقصى المبارك على على خطوره ما
يحدث الان سيكون هناك اشعال لحرب واعتداء
على المسلمين في كل
مكان الفاصل ن لهذا سنسال بعد الفاصل ما
يمكن ان
يفعل استذ رو سنعود لمواصله النقاش في هذه
النقطه التي ذكرتها ولكن بعد ان ناخذ
فاصلا قصيرا نناقش بعده ما ما يج ما الذي
يجب على الفلسطينيين وعلى العرب ايضا فعله
لمواجهه مخططات اسرائيل في الاقصى فلا
تذهب
[موسيقى]
بعيدا اهلا بكم من جديد الى هذه الحلقه
التي تناقش مغزى الاجراءات الاسرائيليه
الاخيره في المسجد الاقصى نرحب بضيوفنا من
جديد استاذ خالد زبرقه يعني في سياق
الحديث عن يمكن فعله هناك اتفاقيه الدفاع
عن القدس والمقدسات تم توقيعها بين الرئيس
محمود عباس وملك الاردن السنه الماضيه
وتلزم ملك الاردن بصفته صاحب الوصايه
وخادم الاماكن المقدسه في القدس بحمايه
الاقصى هل ترون ان الاردن اوفى بالتزاماته
في هذا
المجال الاردن يستطيع ان يقوم بكثير من
الاجراءات لحمايه المسجد الاقصى المبارك
من الاعت داءات الصهيونيه نحن نعتقد ان
الاردن يملك كثير من الاوراق ليضغط بها
على الجانب الاسرائيلي و ايضا على الجانب
الامريكي حتى الان صحيح ان هناك بعض
التصريحات من المسؤولين الاردنيين التي
يعني ارتقت نوعا ما عما كان في السابق لكن
نحن نعتقد انه حتى الان لم ي تقوم المملكه
الاردنيه الهاشميه بدورها المنوط بها
لحمايه المسجد الاقصى المبارك ما يقوم به
الاحتلال ليل نهار من اقتحامات ومن فرض
وجود ومن تهويد ومن تغيير للواقع للواقع
القائم في المسجد الاقصى المبارك وبالتالي
تغيير لما تم الاتفاق عليه بين الاردن
وبين الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يجب ان ترتقي
الاجراءات الاردنيه الى مستوى هذا الحدث
حتى يتم لجم الاحتلال من المضي في
اجراءاته العنصريه او اجراءاته التهويد
للمسجد الاقصى المبارك استاذ اليف صباغ
يعني يعني اسرائيل عندما يعني تتلقى هذا
الكم
من التهديد بان من قبيل تهديد وزير
الاوقاف الاردني بسحب السفراء اذا استمرت
اسرائيل في اعتداءاتها على الاقصى هل تاخذ
يعني على محمل الجد هكذا تهديدات عربيه
واسلاميه
مثلا يعني دعني دعيني اذكر اخت خديجه ما
حدث يوم الج اسرائيل قررت اغلاق المسجد
الاقصى يوم الجمعه الاخير اخر يوم جمعه
ولكن عندما كان الضغط العربي والضغط
الامريكي ضغط حقيقي وعرف بيب نتنياهو انه
سيفجر الاوضاع ولن يستطيع الوقوف امام هذا
التفجير تراجع عن القرار وسمح بالصلاه يوم
الجمعه هذا يثبت ان بيبي نتنياهو بالذات
واسرائيل بشكل عام قابله للضغط عندما يكون
الضغط حقيقي وليس مجرد تصريح الامر الثاني
يعني ملاحظه وارجو ارجو ان تفحص يعني لاني
انا متاكد منها اتفاقيه وادي عربه لا تعطي
للاردن صلاحيات وولايه في المسجد الاقصى
للاسف الشديد اتفاقيه وادي عربه وبالذات
تصريح واشنطن ما يسمى بتصريح واشنطن يقول
ان اسرائيل او اتفاقيه تقول ان اسرائيل
ستمنح الاردن ستمنح الاردن في الحل
النهائي ما كان خاصه في الاماكن المقدسه
الاسلاميه واذا كانت اسرائيل هي التي
ستمنح الاردن معنى ذلك ان اسرائيل هي
صاحبه الحق كيف وقع الاردن على اتفاقيه من
هذا النوع انا لا اعرف وكل ما يقال من
تهديدات جزء منها سيكون تهديد فارغ في
المفهوم الاسرائيلي حقيقه الامر ان الموقف
العربي عامه والاسلامي عامه لا ي يعني لا
يفيد كثيرا بقدر ما ان يكون الموقف
الطين مليار
ونص
مليون هذا التفسيريه وادي عرب وما ذكرت
ليس اعتياديا دع ناخذ راي استاذ الرويدي
في هذا الكلام تفضل استاذ
احمد فيما قيل عن اتفاقيه وادي
عربه
تح هناك
تنسيق
تفضل
الحقيقه يعني دعيني اوضح ان هناك تنسيق
متكامل ما بين الجانب الفلسطيني والجانب
الاردني وهناك الحقيقه دور اردني مهم جدا
نقدره بشكل عالن على المستوى الذي يرقى
الى الحدث وانا متتبع بشكل جيد لكل
المواقف الاردنيه سواء من الملك عبد الله
الثاني او من قبل وزير الخارجيه الاردني
ومن قبل وزير الاوقاف الاردني ووصلت الى
حد الطلب بالغاء اتفاقيه وادي عاره وانهاء
اتفاقيه السلام ما بين الاردن واسرائيل
اذا استمرت اسرائيل في هذا النهج باعتداء
على المسجد الاقصى المبارك وباعتقادي ان
الضغط الاردني والضغط الامريكي مع الضغط
الفلسطيني الشعبي هو الذي دفع نتنياهو يوم
الجمعه الماضي الى التراجع عن موقف خطير
جدا نستطيع ان نفهم منه ما الذي يخطط له
مستقبلا لانه اذا استمعت الى التصريح بشكل
جيد هو قال او اذا كان هذا الضغط فاعلا
كما تقول لماذا لا يستمر والمسلمين من
دخول المسجد الاقصى
ال الحقيقه اسرائيل لا تلتزم باي اتفاقيات
ونحن ندرك ذلك وبالتالي نفهم ان الارض شيء
وتصريحات الاسرائيليه شيء لكن علينا ان
نعمل بكل الاتجاهات هناك عمل سياسي وهذا
مهم جدا نحن بتواصل مع جامعه الدول
العربيه واليوم كان هناك جلسه على مستوى
المندوبين بطلب من الكويت وايضا هناك
تواصل مع منظمه تعاون الاسلامي هناك تواصل
مع الاداره الامريكيه في هذا الشان لكن
اكثر شيء نعول عليه الحقيقه هو شعبنا
الموجود في القدس مع اهلنا من داخل الخط
الاخضر الذين اعلنوا رساله واضحه بان
نتنياهو رغم انه اضاف 1000 شرطي جديد الى
قوات امنه ورغم كل اجراءاته وتعقيداته على
المقدسيين الا ان لديهم اصرار ثابت وواضح
ان هذا المقدس لا يمكن ان يسمحوا بالمساس
به باي شكل من الاشكال وبالتالي هو يحسب
حساب على الارض اكثر من الحسابات السياسيه
والذي دفع الى التراجع الى جانب الضغط
السياسي والمسار السياسي انا اعتقد المسار
الشعبي في داخل القدس الذ استطاع ان يفجر
الوضع في
وجه لانه 47 عاما لم يستطيع ان يغير
انتماء الشعب الفلسطيني
خالدز
الخيارات الخيارات المفتوحه اليوم
فلسطينيا عربيا واسلاميا ما الافق
فيها يعني حقيقه انا اريد ان اصدق ان
الضغط الاردني والفلسطيني والامريكي
السياسي هو الذي منع اغلاق المسجد الاقصى
المبارك لكن اذا كان هذا هو الحل فحقي
وجدنا ضالتنا وممكن وممكن من الان وصاعدا
ان نمنع الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ان يقوم بكل
اجراءاته داخل المسجد الاقصى المبارك لكن
هذا هو بعيد عن الواقع انا باعتقادي انه
الان الجانب الشعبي هو المؤثر وهو الذي
يؤثر على السياسه الاسرائيليه ولذلك نحن
نطالب بال السلطه الفلسطينيه ان تطلق
العنان للجانب الشعبي في الضفه الغربيه
ليقوم بدوره لنصره القدس والمسجد الاقصى
المبارك ايضا نحن نطالب ايضا الشعوب
العربيه في كل اماكن تواجدها ان تتحرك في
يعني فعاليات ونشاطات من اجل فرض ضغط
سياسي على النظام السياسي العربي ليقوم ب
باجراءات حقيقيه لحمايه المسجد الاقصى
المبارك الوضع خطير جدا جدا اليوم المسجد
الاقصى المبارك في عين الخط خطر اصبح
المخططات الاسرائيليه جاهزه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي يحاول ان
يستغل الوضع الاقليمي والظرف الاقليمي
المحيط بالقدس وبالمسجد الاقصى المبارك
هناك انظمه عربيه تتساوق مع خطاب الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ومع مخططات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ولذلك نحن نريد اليوم ان يتحرك
الوضع او يتحرك الجانب الشعبي من اجل ان
يقلب الطاوله على رموز الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في كل مكان شكرا لك خالد زبرقه
عضو المكتب السياسي للحركه الاسلاميه داخل
الخط الاخضر ومدير مؤسسه القدس للتنميه
نشكر ايضا الاستاذ احمد الرويضي مستشار
ديوان الرئاسه الفلسطينيه لشؤون القدس كنت
معنا من القدس ونشكر ضيفنا من الناصره
الاستاذ اليف صباغ الكاتب والباحث في
الشؤون الاسرائيليه شكرا لكم جميعا وبهذا
تنتهي هذه الحلقه من ناج ما وراء الخبر
لكم منا اطيب المنى والى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء